qué intereses tiene China en la región
de América Central particularmente en
Honduras
es una situación muy particular la que
estamos observando porque en principio
parecería que no es una cuestión central
para la gran estrategia de China este
reconocimiento que ha logrado por parte
de centroamericano Sin embargo aquí el
punto es que casualmente Taiwán es solo
reconocido a nivel internacional por 14
estados de los cuales ocho se encuentran
en América Central El Caribe y América
del Sur en consecuencia cada país cada
país que reconozca a esta entidad
política que está igual cuenta mucho y
por lo tanto entonces china ha alcanzado
un importante logro diplomático Qué
consecuencias cree que podría tener esta
medida sobre lo que son las relaciones
entre Honduras y Estados Unidos no
teniendo en cuenta los vínculos
tensionados entre China y Washington
sí efectivamente es una realidad que
desde Washington se está ejerciendo
presión sobre aquellos países no solo de
América Central El Caribe y América del
Sur sino también de Oceanía que son una
zona de influencia importante para los
Estados Unidos para que no lleven a
cambio lleven a cargo Perdón Este cambio
diplomático Entonces yo creo que en las
próximas semanas e incluso meses vamos a
ver cada vez un protagonismo mayor de
Washington en Estados como Belice
Guatemala que son los que en el caso de
América Central aún reconocen a Taiwán
desde el lado hondureño Cómo explica
este acercamiento qué intereses tiene
Honduras
bueno En primer término Aquí es
importante la cuestión ideológica el
posicionamiento político ideológico de
la actual gobierno pero al mismo tiempo
también es una realidad lo atractiva que
son las inversiones el financiamiento
que china puede ofrecer para por ejemplo
llevar a cabo una serie de obras de
infraestructura en ese país tengamos en
cuenta que hoy en día china ofrece ese
pegamento llamado la nueva ruta de la
seda o la franja y la ruta que incluye
principalmente el desarrollo de obras de
infraestructura